voilà à véronique sanson jeune homme est
extrait de son nouvel album longue
distance alors c'est une chanson quand
on écoute un petit peu les paroles c'est
une chanson assez assez menaçante quand
même non en fait c'est une crise dont
100 sont vraiment qui concerne tout le
monde s'est tu sais c'est jamana mais
vous pourrez dire j'aime une femme si
c'est très universel
c'est simplement on dit ne fais pas
chier ouais parce que si tu me fais
chier c'est toi qui vas morfler et j'ai
peur pour toi que tu m'abandonnes ouais
c'est parce que j'ai peur pour moi je
m'en fous parce que c'est un [ __ ] à
une autre chanson qui s'appelle la
douceur du danger
les paroles sont très très ma vie
sentimentale n'est plus qu'un vide
sidéral rien à regarder dans ma boule de
cristal je jabba matta pau ouest
non non c'est vrai et ma vie non c'est
vrai c'est quand on n'a rien à dire
quand on a rien pas même pendant 6 ans
n'ont pas envie d'écrire on n'a pas
envie de 2
on n'a pas de vécu on n'a pas de d'amour
on n'a pas de
on n'a rien donc qu'est ce qu'on fait on
ferme sa gueule ça a duré six ans le oui
l'incapacité finalement qu'à piste et
c'est pas c'est parce que je n'étais pas
capable c'était simplement que je que je
m'en foutais complètement j'avais rien à
dire je ne vivais rien et franchement
j'avais rien à dire ne rien rien de rien
je plantais mes carottes et je peux le
plan
comment commencer revenus l'envi décrire
le beau le goût de la vie simplement
l'urgence simplement quand on m'a dit on
m'a dit tu rentre en studio le 18
et moi j'ai dit mais j'ai rien de prêt
je viens de près et donc j'ai écrit à
toute vitesse
pas mal pour un truc écrit à toute
vitesse dit non non mais a tout dit m ça
veut pas dire barclays 1
ce n'est pas ma clé tandis que le
peintre auxerre de la fleur pendant 20
ans et qu'y la croque en 30 secondes
voilà six ans temps magazine et voilà il
ya une autre chanson qui s'appelle
cinquième étage alors c'est drôle parce
que vos parents avaient acheté un
appartement au cinquième étage oui il
s'était donné beaucoup de mal brunch est
important de donner beaucoup de mal
j'avais je sais je me souviens qu'ils
avaient des chaussures en papier un à
l'époque parce que il avait il avait
plus un rond et puis que c'était la fin
de la guerre qu'ils étaient tous des
qualifiés qui s'était tout ce que je
peux voir et puis je me suis aperçu que
le 5e étage
c'était eux et puis le 5e étage c'est ma
soeur ouais le 5e étage
c'est moi aussi et et tout le monde que
j'aime vie au cinquième étage de
poursuivre franchement franchement je
voulais écrire quelque chose pour ma
famille parce que quand quand on aime
les gens il faut il faut leur dire qu'on
les ait moins avant que ce sera trop
tard
si à un moment où vous étiez malade vous
êtes dit si je disparaissais je voudrais
leur laisser quelque chose avant de
partir et qui sont malades et il faut
qu'ils entendre une chanson voilà ouais
alors votre père était était avocat 1
mais ses avocats et aux îles à tous deux
il était député du xiiie a renvoie là où
il est il était
économiste il travaillait avec giscard
et puis avec chirac aussi
non mais il était cité c'était un type
absolument extraordinaire s'étaient
rencontrés pendant la résistance
oui pendant la résistance et donc ils
ont maman était enfin ils étaient tous
les deux dans le renseignement
un papa organisé par exemple grâce à ces
renseignements le les bombardements
contre les allemands sur l'afrique du
nord et en italie et à corfou aussi et
et à corfou bien sûr et à corfou et puis
maman et est une très grande savonneuse
ah ah oui elle était spécialiste en en
sabotages et en vraiment en plastique
elle s'y connaît
moi j'ai voulu un jour j'avais une
souche mais il enleva bhl énorme souche
et je lui dis mais en inde
il donne moi la recette du plastique
jamais voulu le dire moi même la recette
du club sandwich mais j'aurais donné
elle est très comme ça ta mère et garde
ses côtés
alors je les embrasse et faux pas je
t'embrasse
ils vous regardent alors votre père donc
et votre mère se sont rencontrés pendant
pendant la résistance
il est très mélomane est très jeune ils
vous ont mis à la musique alors vous ce
qui est incroyable c'est que vous
connaissiez pas le solfège et en fait
vous entendiez la chanson jouée par le
par le professeur de piano et vous la
répétiez en faisant semblant de
déchiffrer une partition et un jour ce
n'est pas la bonne partition et la prof
c'est ça la personne qu'en fait c'était
voilà à quoi vous saviez pas elle s'est
aperçue que je l'avais berné pendant
quand même pas mal d'années et elle
s'appelait mahina robur et puis aussi
pim pim qui doit être archi morte
maintenant sûr pas sur ce tracé voir les
morts
alors à l'âge de 13 ans vous écrivez vos
premières chansons c'est assez précoce
et à 14 ans un jour vous êtes à monaco
il ya une bombe qui explose dans votre
tête
véronique sanson c'est à dire que vous
croyez que c'est un attentat au départ
c'est vrai j'ai une bombe dans ma tête
c'était et ce serait tout simplement une
méningite et et puis là vraiment j'ai
j'en ai bavé parce que papa est ce que
en plus j'ai reçues quand même l'extrême
onction
non c'est plus grave c'est à dire vrai
la zac du l'énergie de quoi vous étiez
quand même donné pour mort votre père
vous a ramené à paris tout raide à raide
comme la justice hésite mais ouais et
ghazi et ma soeur violaine me gaver de
deux dvi en fuite et à l'époque vous
souvenez de lévis en fuite et il est la
palombe latif un punk l'a61 et moi
évidemment
non je pouvais pas je pouvais papillon
bon après on m'a emmené à l'hôpital et
que et voilà je suis reste 15 jours
d'hosto deux mois de combats les 100
jours et tu parles way qui en plus des
fonctions d'air exactement et toi un
jour c'était c'était mais on sent par
contre je m'en souviens plus j'ai perdu
la mémoire après tout ce qui s'est passé
avant 65
vous l'avez oublié oui même les jours où
j'étais protégé pognon gtd rendu n'est d
espèce de réminiscences comme ça c'est à
dire par exemple convoyer des bagues en
toc
vous vous dites ça vous rappelle quelque
chose mais vous savez pas quoi puisque
vous avez perdu la mémoire dépendance à
débat vain la wells à bull fait là quand
vous voyez des wagons toth débat dans ta
voix là vous vous dites que ça vous
rappelle quelque chose mais vous savez
pas quoi c'était quelque chose qui a dû
arriver avant 1965 avant la méningite
j'imagine alors véronique à
l'adolescence vous montez votre premier
groupe avec votre soeur et françois
berne même qui depuis est devenu un
compositeur connu puisqu'il travaille
pour patricia kaas le groupe s'appelle
les roches martha vous fait vos premiers
disent que vous rencontrez
michel berger vous découvrez votre
fameux vibrato qui a fait votre votre
gloire vos premières scènes au premier
tube i là quand ça commence à vraiment
bien marché pour vous vous plaquer tout
comment ça je perds tout va ou plaqué to
spend à loupiac et où vous partez aux
états unis avec stephen stills
ah oui les gens souvenez que ça quand
même
oui ça fait quand même une sacrée
histoire de rappeler à nos amis c'est
fun style ses grosses bises still nash
et après young qui plutonium d'ailleurs
pu tellement lourd que je vous flashez
sur ses fans s'ils sur les sur les
champs-elysées et puis du jour au
lendemain sans prévenir personne sans
prévenir un michel berger sans prévenir
vos parents vous partez d'abord aux
états unis à new york
bouger je me souviens très bien d'avoir
atterri et a été je suis allé un concert
où il y avait mais alors quelqu'un dont
je suis un grand fut grande fan itude
c'est vrai dîner ou même un et on met
une chaise sur scène j'avais une chance
pas possible de dire qu'on met comme ça
et j'ai trop je me suis dit c'est sam
york
c'est ça les états unis c'est ce à quoi
et après on est parti en angleterre se
marier eva et c'est vrai que j'ai
abandonné quelque chose et qui me et
j'ai abandonné quelque chose de
terriblement important alors quand vous
partez en fait partie comme ça sur un
coup de tête quoi oui hein
et alors vos parents préviennent vos
parents préviennent interpol cirque on
bourre cherche
oui moi j'avais été piqué mon passeport
je suis mes parents puis voilà et puis
moi je suis parti je me suis dit est ce
là où on lève j'ai un train à prendre
voilà il faut que je le prenne le train
à cette époque souligné michel berger
quand même non bien sûr je l'aimais et
pourra vous êtes parti alors pour rire
ouais juste pour rire pour pour
connaître quelque chose d'autre bien sûr
que je l'aimais j'aime toujours j'ai
fait un concert avec un symphonique
justement pour me dédouaner et et pour
payer ma dette
quand vous épousez stephen stills à
l'époque qu'est ce que c'est pas un peu
pour justifier votre départ si si si je
me suis absolument marier par politesse
mais c'est ça ce que tout le monde était
là un y avait les beatles y avait les
vous savez dont je me foutait
complètement mais il y avait mes parents
et ses parents et je dis je peux pas je
pensais et ma soeur m'a dit moi j'ai ma
voiture la plus sûre aux casse s'est dit
quand même si c'est mal élevé devant les
beatles
avec tous ces cols sandwich et ben je me
suis payé par politesse mais j'ai bien
fait parce que j'ai beaucoup aimé cet
homme ne mène pas comme michel michel c
ce sera toujours quelque chose je sais
pas comment me dire le jour du mariage
d'être consciente que vous êtes en train
de faire une connerie
ah oui vaut également une énorme
connerie et je me dis mais tous les gens
sont là c'est effrayant
et en plus on avait une mairesse en
angleterre dont celle à l'angleterre il
sort en angleterre qui ressemblait comme
deux gouttes aux marques qui allaient
script lindy un ornithorynque merci donc
oui donc là vous avez le sentiment en
fait d'entrer en enfer le jour du
mariage alors la seule bonne nouvelle
c'est votre fils christopher hausse 10,1
quand même et alors là ça commence par
là vous avez connu vous la vraie vie de
rock star des années 70 quoi c'est à
dire marijuana lsd et cocaïne
non trop light trop sonore non lsd
cocaïne héroïne des atouts un tout petit
peu quand vincent cocaïne un peu un peu
plus
enfin dans le temps que les autres
heureusement pour les connaître
j'ai connu dès lors après six ou sept
ans avec stephen stills le couple ça
vire au cauchemar parce que lui il
picole pas mal il se défonce pas mal et
il est assez violent avec vous non ouais
ah oui ça alors dit
très violent et j'ai reçu des coups de
couteau dans le dos et ça n'est pas du
bien
veillez cicatrices mai encore oui la
pâte avec le manche et non mais
heureusement il m'a raté un creusement
il m'arrêter vie m'a donné aussi un coup
de couteau dans la main un juste avant
un concert
eh ben j'ai joué ou y ait du sens parts
1ère le sens et ce qui est effrayant de
sueur sur scène c'est que le sang
d'abord ça c'est affreux parce que ça ça
glisse puis après ça colle ça couru et
on vivait dans ça va bon ça c'est les
baisers fait l'histoire enfin l'histoire
c'est la grande histoire du rock and
roll
c'est vrai nom est vraiment dans le coup
tout genre y avait des choses absolument
chaotique à cette époque bien qu'on lui
dit non ce n'est jamais alors
le plus difficile pour vous ça a été
d'obtenir la garde de votre fils parce
qu'au départ vous aviez le droit de le
voir une fois toutes les trois semaines
à condition de rester aux états unis
et là vous êtes aperçu de ce qui pouvait
se raconter dans ce genre de procès dans
ce genre d'histoire cirque par exemple
on disait aux états unis que les
français mettaient du cognac dans le
biberon
mais si on vous en vous accusez le
maître vu que d'actualité
les français vous vous ayez raison parce
que au moins nous on se tape une nuit
d'enfer mais vous mettez du cognac ils
s'endorment
ouais et puis aussi qu'on faisait dormir
nos bébés dans les tiroirs un oui quand
ils sont bien sûr mer d'ordre les
tiroirs
quand vous êtes arrivé en france après
ce séjour américain véronique ça a été
terrible pour vous parce que d'un seul
coup vous sortiez quand même de cette
vie absolument délirantes et puis vous
vous retrouvez dans votre maison sur les
bords de seine avec etienne chicot ça
doit être quand même grave descente non
en oui alors ça c'était une grave
descente je veux bien le croire
je veux bien le croire pas à cause de la
descente des états unis
j'en dirai pas plus ouais et puis après
ça
alors j'étais très en avance parce que
allah c'était en 1988 et c'était
l'histoire d'une femme kamikaze
la fille elle va avec sa robe rose avec
une bombe sous sont sous sa robe en
prétendant être enceinte ou quelque
chose comme ça et puis elle va se
suicider au nom d'allah qui promet le
paradis éternel et c'est ça que c'est
comme ça qu'on a les gens et serge et je
trouvais que j'étais à l'époque enfin il
y avait une espèce de tolérance l'atroce
quoi et puis d'envoyer des petits ce cd
jantes 18 ans ces gens de 16 ans des
gens de 20 ans et si jamais des lieux un
sait jamais non ils ont volé petit
rouaix sa salle et orange en plus ces
espèces de mensonges de toutes les
religions de toutes les religions les
religions menthe
alors on peut très bien croire à un être
supérieur disons ou un ange irradiant
moi je crois au mien il appelle henri
lieux chauds et sinon je serais morte
depuis longtemps
c'est pour ça je vous ai tout à l'heure
je suis tellement content de me
réveiller violente
c'est grâce à lui mais je crois pas un
dieu qu'à une barbe est sur un petit
nuage
ça j'y crois pas mais je crois pas ce
qu'on nous dit dans la bible je crois
pas ce qu'on nous dit dans l'est dans
l'évangile le catéchisme à la con suis
désolé pour pour les prêtres et les gens
qui sont bien enfin des gens qui sont
vraiment bien parce que j'en ai connu
moi mais autrement tous les autres ils
apprennent le pire
le purgatoire qu'est ce que c'est le
purgatoire c'est quoi non mais
franchement c'est quoi c'est un resto il
ya que des clubs sandwichs à ce qu'on va
dire
la vision que j'en ai à l'époque vous
avez eu des menaces à l'époque de hal à
des menaces des islamistes
je crois pas que ce soit des sages et
étaient des islamistes je crois que
c'était à l'époque ddd dire est d'aider
des skins et des gens d'extrême droite
parce que j'ai reçu tellement de lettres
n'ont pas d'islamisme et de musulmans et
qui m'ont dit on a honte on a honte
et puis après il ya sa place à kembo
gross et des cheveux courts mais dure
depuis to see the pips des grosses
qualités cheveux qu il nous faisait rire
pierre
ah oui oui j ai continué à me faire rire
bien sûr ça nous a fait énormément de
peine quand on s'est mariés que tout le
monde dise que c'était que c'était de la
foutaise et et tout ça nous a fait de la
peine ça fait de la peine à lui la peine
à moi surtout parce que lui plus fort
que moi et il s'en sort mieux que moi et
ça nous a fait de la peine et notre
divorce aussi je regrette rien parce
qu'on est toujours aussi amis et on est
toujours aussi mais pour les fans pour
les fans dont je fais partie tu le sais
avant qu'on se connaît se disait toute
l'admiration d'un mois que j'ai pour toi
c'est compliqué parce que moi j'ai
rectifié tous mes albums chez moi donc
c'est quand même du travail de changer
les noms à chaque fois donc là il me
reste six places
j'ai fait ça sent tous mes disques et
sur mon passeport il ya toujours des
ennuis pallanne ça les fait marrer les
douaniers n'ont pas tous oui madame
badman vous parlez souvent une pierre
danon ben oui très souvent et pierre je
dois dire que c'est c'est quelqu'un de
je crois que c'est la personne la plus
protectrice que je connaisse de mes
vieux hommes quoi que il a beau avoir 19
ans mon coin pour moi c'est un vieux
mais enfin c'est un type bourré de
talent est formidable et et franchement
je je je ne l'oublient pas je loupe pas
avec france gall comment ça va là mais
je ne sais pas vous êtes pareils
concilier depuis l'époque où elle vous
traitez de boeuf joyeuse non non c'est
jamais parlé ouais avec jamais en fait
non jamais oui jamais mais j'ai dit un
truc dans un
dans un journal j'ai dis quand même que
les deux seules personnes qui étaient
capables de chanter michel berger c'est
france gall et moi j'aurais dû le faire
plaisir pas de nouvelle bonne nouvelle
d'accord et donc c'est et dakar c stand
by comme on dit oui alors quand vous
pensez à votre vie comme ça vous dit ni
remords ni regrets si c'était à refaire
je le referais tout même les malheurs
même les souffrances c'est vrai
malheureusement et les regrets on n'est
pas tellement c'est vrai curieux les
remords j'en ai un tout petit peu belle
vie quand même non j'ai bien écouté oui
je me suis bien marré j'ai bien souffert
et puis je me suis dit 'tiens gerona q2
mais sambre gym ou rue des belles
couleurs et en sons g sterner
bon
mais les pros
oui je t'aime
mais bon vouloir
m
en tout huit ans
il y a
à
à quoi sert la main
il avoue
nous alors